i tell you what my fellow barbecue
lovers get ready for a short drive to
mesquite for the annual barbecue fest at
casablanca resort and casino christian
anderson joins us from casablanca with
the juicy info this is going to be a lot
of fun you've got some guys who are
making amazing barbecue we do we're
excited if you're a barbecue fan you
gotta get to the casablanca this weekend
we have three great vendors coming down
uh they have over 500 national awards
for their barbecue so if you love
barbecue
the casablanca's being the place to be
this weekend yeah and you always and
you've got a lot of stuff going on this
fall you've got the car show the very
next week this is one where people get
to come in and sample from these
different vendors yeah you know it's a
great thing about this event it's a
great family-friendly event so bring the
kids up this weekend get some barbecue
it's free to attend you got to pay for
the the fantastic barbecue we have a
great beer garden up there of course got
to pay for that great beer but there's a
lot of stuff to do we're going to be
doing watermelon contest for the kids we
have the principles of all the local
schools of mesquite competing at
watermelon contest casablanca is going
to give 500 that winning school and then
we have the police and fire department
going head-to-head in the eating contest
a thousand dollars their charity of
choice away into the oh that's so cool
uh so they pay at each individual vendor
for barbecue or is that a one price and
then you get to eat as much as you want
they pay for each at each individual
vendor and we encourage them to try all
the barbecue because it's all good right
and the great part of it is that there's
a people's choice so they can only try
them all but they can vote for their
favorite and then the cost of one gives
two thousand dollars cash the winning
vendor has the most votes at the end of
the weekend that is great and why do you
enjoy having so many community events as
you guys do and giving back in the
process absolutely you know the mesquite
community has been very good of the
casablanca and mesquite gaming and
anytime we do an event you know the
people that come in with tourism i think
it's great they leave a mark on the
community they enjoy and like to
come and see and the the casablanca rip
fest is no different you know that those
people coming in enjoy the event but we
also give back to that community and and
the community supports us so well does
your demo end up being largely from
southern utah or is it an even split
between here and southern utah yeah we
have fans in las vegas and southern utah
and both like to converge on the at the
casa blanca for barbecue events
anytime you have good barbecue it's
going to bring people from all over the
place so yeah we're looking forward to
bringing those people back in this
weekend and enjoying some great food and
enjoying a great resort at the
casablanca starts friday at what time uh
friday uh one o'clock in the afternoon
so skip that lunch come on up to the
casablanca grab some barbecue and we'll
be doing barbecue all the way through
sunday uh great football going on all
weekend long we'll have tailgate
activities a great beer garden and all
that great football action going on in
inside our events center so enjoy some
barbecue enjoy some football it goes
hand in hand we're going to cool off for
you on saturday yeah we're
we're hoping so all right christian
thank you so much appreciate you being
here uh you can head out to casablanca
resort and casino and we want to thank
them for sponsoring this segment the
barbecue fest is this weekend september
9th through the 11th if you want more
information it's on our website or you
can call 1877 getaway or go to
casablanca's website at casablanca
resort dot com